[Musique]
allô
sur votre téléphone vous en avez
sûrement plus de 3 ou 4 parfois même
pour certains plus d'une dizaine et il y
en a pour tous les goûts c'est beaucoup
les groupes par exemple bah pour l'école
pour la famille j'ai un groupe chez qui
on va chercher à manger le midi avec le
travail voilà 72% déjà utilisé
l'application un tiers d'entre vous sont
membres de plus de 5 groupes groupe
amicaux et familiaux en tête et Bonne
Nouvelle vous êtes heureux d'y être
heureux jusqu'à un certain point
WhatsApp permet de créer ou maintenir du
lien c'est vrai mais l'hyper connexion
peut aussi rendre fou doit-on avoir peur
de toi tchatche BD il est important de
comprendre que je suis un programme
informatique et donc je n'ai pas de
sentiments ou d'intention
ce n'est pas la capacité de causer du
mal ou de nuire à qui que ce soit
cependant il est important de s'assurer
que les informations que je fournis sont
utilisées de manière responsable selon
une étudiof 58% des utilisateurs sont
dérangés par le nombre de messages et
plus d'un tiers d'entre eux sont énervés
par des membres du groupe je vais vous
proposer un petit test de quotient
intellectuel pour mesurer un petit peu
vos cerveaux
relou la Go c'est bon c'est que tes
maîtresses tu as le QI de Einstein c'est
bon on connaît pas tous obligés de côtes
un peu bête quoi dans la méthodologie
voilà plus d'un an qui Eden a plongé
dans la spirale TikTok dès qu'il ouvre
l'application je reste pendant des
heures des heures des heures des heures
entrant de scroller comme ça des fois je
me dis que je prends je prends beaucoup
de temps à passer sur TikTok j'étudie
pas assez après éviter d'être distrait
non non Tik Tok n'abruti pas nos enfants
au contraire c'est le réseau de la
grande littérature c'est le d'Augustin
trapenard
c'est la communauté littéraire de Tik
Tok et ça va vous faire redécouvrir la
littérature toutes les littérature alors
nuance de wesh allez-y bah il y a le
wesh bonjour wesh bonjour wesh bonjour
wesh il y a le wesh surpris wesh
je suis surpris ah mais vous êtes super
comédienne je ne peux pas lire tout ça
je ne supporte plus de devoirs toujours
rire Oui mais ou ajouter des cœurs à
chaque pensée photos ou blagues envoyées
ici signé un vieux grincheux né avant
les portables mais il existe aussi des
solutions moins radicales comme la mise
en sourdine des notifications
je voulais juste me présenter je
m'appelle Jean-Luc weshman bah voilà
parfait wesh mangue plus personne
t'imagine mais ouais certains c'est
qu'on pourrait fermer tous les réseaux
sociaux
c'est un truc mais c'est immonde ça nous
détruit la société c'est un truc c'est
une la pire catastrophe
aussi beaucoup de choses
en fait
les tâches etc on peut distinguer Robert
de René par exemple
tu peux lui refaire un passeport
biométrique individualisé alors à quoi
est-ce que ça sert à voyager on a 18 ans
laissez-moi partager mes informations
avec les Chinois si j'en ai envie
fais beau geste de Killian Mbappé pour
la population turque près d'un mois
après les séismes qui ont frappé le pays
le footballeur a publié hier soir ce
tweet vu par plus de 25 millions
d'internautes en commentaire beaucoup de
cœur et de remerciements peu avant bapé
avait participé à une émission
caritative à la télé turque l'attaquant
a promis d'utiliser tous les moyens à sa
disposition pour aider les victimes
l'ouverture des débats aujourd'hui au
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites les
discussions ont démarré dans un
hémicycle plutôt apaisé loin du
spectacle offert par une partie des
députés à l'Assemblée nationale le
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal a d'ailleurs rendu hommage aux
tempéraments pondéré des sénateurs en
taquant au passage sans les nommer les
députés de la nupesse je sais qu'ici par
de là les divergences politiques on
s'écoute
je sais qu'ici par de la les oppositions
de fond on débat je sais qu'ici par de
là les parcours de chacun on se respecte
je sais qu'ici il n'y a pas de ZAD il
n'y a que la République et même un
poisson qui nous a rejoint et quel
poisson avec avec le propriétaire de ce
poisson
mettre la France à l'arrêt ce serait
laissé filer une crise qu'on peut encore
éviter
l'absence de pluie depuis plus de 30
jours maintenant en France fait peser un
risque extrêmement fort sur l'état de
nos réserves en eau cet été mettre le
pays à l'arrêt c'est prendre le risque
d'une catastrophe écologique agricole
sanitaire voire humaine dans quelques
mois
[Musique]
dans quoi la dosation monsieur verlan un
peu de sérieux là sécheresse c'est la
faute des syndicats la crise sanitaire
idem et pourquoi pas la défaite en Coupe
du Monde vos tentatives pour
décrédibiliser une mobilisation sans
précédent contre les 64 ans sont
grossières bah il a il a pas tout à fait
peur
ça augmentera le nombre de cancers de
l'utérus
syndicat de médecins libéraux menace
démasculer François Braun dans un
communiqué le Hamel rappelle être dirigé
je cite par une chirurgienne
parfaitement capable de pratiquer
l'ablation de tout appendice dépassant
du corps et qui aurait pu perturber le
processus des négociations